auch die musikwelt ist in trauer ja
viele megastars hat die queen in den
adelsstand erhoben und viele schätzen
sie als kennerin der kultur
die queen und die musik es ist eine ganz
besondere verbindung und einige der
größten stars wurde die ehre zuteil zum
ritter geschlagen zu werden dürfen
seitdem den titel sie in ihrem namen
tragen
1997 wurde paul mccartney sänger der
legendären beatles zum ritter geschlagen
so paul mccartney zum tod der queen gott
schütze queen elizabeth die zweite möge
sie in frieden ruhen lang lebe der könig
auch er darf den titel sir tragen elton
john titel wie candle in the wind am
standing und rocketman machten den
briten zum megastar auf instagram
spricht er seine tiefste trauer aus
zusammen mit dem rest der nation bin ich
zutiefst traurig über die nachricht vom
tod ihrer majestät königin elizabeth sie
war eine inspirierende präsenz und
führte das land mit anmut anstand und
einer aufrichtigen fürsorglichen wärme
durch einige unserer größten und
dunkelsten momente queen elizabeth war
von kindheit an bis heute ein großer
teil meines lebens und ich werde sie
sehr vermissen ebenfalls von der queen
zum ritter geschlagen war morrison
wieder nordiren einem interview beteuert
bedeutet ihm dieser titel nichts er
halte es für einen vollkommen
belanglosen titel anders ist das bei
bono sänger der band youtube das problem
bono ist kein gebürtiger brite besitzt
keinen britischen pass der in irland
geborene sänger darf daher den titel
nicht tragen
auch rod stewart ringo starr oder mick
jagger wurden zum ritter geschlagen
jedoch nicht von der queen persönlich
sondern von prinz charles jetzt könig
charles oder prinz william die rolling
stones legende schreibt ihr instagram
mein ganzes leben lang war ihre majestät
königin elizabeth die zweite immer da
ich kann mich erinnern dass ich in
meiner kindheit ihre hochzeit highlights
im fernsehen gesehen habe ich erinnere
mich an sie als eine wunderschöne junge
dame an die viel geliebte großmutter der
nation mein tiefstes mitgefühl gilt der
königlichen familie die musikwelt auch
sie trauert um königin elizabeth
[Musik]